also ich habe wirklich angst vor irgend
welchen nebenwirkungen und ja ich möchte
das einfach akzeptiert wird ich schütze
mich ich werde gehen jeden tag zum
testen also eigentlich
kann dem bewohner nicht passieren weil
wir auf uns achten
das sieht ihre kollegin wenn die streit
sich aber anders
gerade die die jetzt sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen besonders in der pflege
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen sind für
mich egoisten weil sie in dem moment ja
nur an sich denken und nicht an die
bewohner
mit grauen denkt sie an das zurück was
sie vor einem jahr auf ihre stationen im
pflegeheim erlebt hat
das war schon schlimm ist ein teilweise
bewohner früher rumgelaufen und
nachmittag als wir sind links kompanie
tot gewesen also das hat schon auch mit
uns was gemacht also wir haben ja
unglaube in kürzester zeit sind 20
bewohner verstorben ancona es war glaubt
so dezember/januar zeit falls ja das war
schon schlimm für uns und schon deswegen
rat ich impfen zu gehen
doch noch kann sich die call nicht dazu
durchringen und fürchtet sich vor dem
was kommen könnte
natürlich davor dass ich nie mehr
arbeiten auf natürlich
ich kann ja alles passieren das macht
doch auch mit einem was im kopf also
nicht gut bin ich alles weil wie gesagt
ich liebe den beruf
und die heimbewohner lieben ihre
pflegekräfte egal ob geimpft oder nicht
sigma nowitzki weiß genau ohne seine
pflegekräfte wird's eng
doch für pflegedienstleiterin mirella
1000 ist klar sie kann nicht auf einen
einzigen mitarbeiter verzichten im
letzten zwei jahren ist die situation
manchmal so angespannt gewesen das war
gar nicht wussten wie wie es noch
weitergehen
und dann wurde im dezember letzten
jahres die branchenbezogene impfpflicht
beschlossen ein dilemma begann in vielen
einrichtungen auch auf der station von
mirella 1000 im pflegeheim in
hoyerswerda denn von ihren 35
mitarbeitern waren bis vor kurzem 8
ungeimpft im team begannen heftige
diskussionen die alltagsprobleme die
vermischten sich dann plötzlich mit den
gegner und
ich habe schon manchmal gedacht ich muss
mich entschuldigen dafür dass ich
geimpft bin also das war schon manchmal
eine richtige herausforderung da war es
dann wirklich ist so dieser frust dem
wir alle gespürt haben und das war
teilweise schon wirklich eskalieren wo
man wirklich eingreifen musste und
schlichten musste und nach möglichkeit
im dienstplan bist dann so regeln dass
die nicht zusammen eingeteilt sind
dabei haben sie alle die schlimme zeit
anfang letzten jahres gemeinsam erlebt
als so viele heimbewohner starben und
mitarbeiter sich infizierten gerade so
meine mitarbeiter die in den genesenen
status letztes jahr noch hatten die dann
gesagt haben also das was ich erlebt
habe so krank wie ich war das wünsche
ich niemanden und ich lasse mich auf
jeden fall impfen und plötzlich waren
die auf einer ganz anderen welle
unterwegs und haben
sich gegen das impfen entschieden also
das war das was ich überhaupt nicht
verstehen konnte
über das thema diskutieren möchte keiner
mehr auf den fluren des heims will man
nicht mehr darüber sprechen zu
festgefahren sind die meinungen
ich würde sagen die mitarbeiter die sich
nicht impfen lassen weise vor
irgendetwas angst haben dass der
impfstoff mit denen macht kann ich es
nicht verstehen weil
alkohol trinken rauchen tun sie
schlimme sachen tun sei essen von daher
überlegen sei auch nicht was der körper
mit dem macht und ich denke zum peak
sowie sagen dazu nichts mehr ja am
anfang aber viel darüber gesprochen aber
ich denke es bringt nichts ist so eine
eingefahrene schiene nur gerade die sich
wirklich nicht impfen lassen wollen und
die aktions mittlerweile
trotz unterschiedlicher meinung können
sie gut miteinander arbeiten schätzen
sich sehr ist der druck auch etwas raus
nachdem in sachsen eine art
übergangsfrist bis zum jahresende
geschaffen wurde damit es sich jeder
mitarbeiter noch mal mit der impfung
überlegen und weiterarbeiten kann denn
heimbewohner und pflegekräfte sind hier
ein team
geschäftsführer markus beyer frustriert
vor allem dass er von der politik
keinerlei antworten auf wichtige fragen
bekommt
also ich bin kein freund von ad hoc
entscheidungen allerdings muss man
natürlich sehen wir brauchen irgendwann
mal eine aussage wir handeln sollen und
die ist halt nicht gegeben und das ist
für uns die schwierigkeit sofern wir ja
auch von der politik nicht wirklich eine
klare aussage eine klare antwort
erhalten wie wir uns verhalten sollen ab
dem 15 es gibt zwar die möglichkeit der
gesundheitsämter dies signalisiert haben
sie möchten jetzt im moment kein
betretungsverbot aussprechen so fern da
die sachlage auch noch nicht klar ist
allerdings ist es für uns natürlich
schwierig weil wir haben ja auch noch
andere gesetze nämlich das arbeitsrecht
was uns vorgibt wie wir den
arbeitsschutz gewährleisten müssen bei
uns im unternehmen und eine ganz andere
frage die sich mir noch stellt
persönlich ist die haftung die
haftungsfrage was passiert wenn sich
jemand infiziert ab dem 15 egal ob jetzt
mitarbeitende oder auch befunde
und überhaupt habe die arbeiterwohlfahrt
auch bestimmte leitlinien die zumindest
die mitarbeiter nicht außer acht lassen
wollen
am ende haben wir zumindest als awo auch
grundwerte da sind sich die toleranz
toleranz denen gegenüber und jeder
entscheidung gegenüber und die freiheit
bei uns im grundsatz stehen und die
freiheit des einzelnen sich zu
entscheiden und diese toleranz für jeden
einzelnen der sich entscheiden
entschieden hat die sollten wir uns
gegenseitig auch zukommen lassen und das
leben hier
diese freiheit fehle nicoles warte sie
fühlt sich enorm unter druck gesetzt
also manchmal schläft fast gar nicht
mehr also man ist wirklich ständig unter
dauerstrom ich bin eigentlich wohl wenn
ich hier bin denke ich jetzt nicht so
dran war ich mag man ja zu tun aber
zuhause ist natürlich dass arbeitet
smart hören
man habe das gefühl die
gesellschaftlichen probleme werden
gerade allein auf den pflegebereich
verlagert und das schade dem ansehen des
pflegeberufes enorm kaum jemand erinnere
sich noch an die extrem anstrengende
zeit der korona ausbrüche in den heimen
es war furchtbar es war einfach nur
furchtbar also ich hoffe
immer noch heute den hut vor meinen
kollegen wie die das geschafft haben die
sind damen die feier amt hatten und die
aus ihrem auto heraus richtigen sind
waren die clippers die haare waren als
die wahren schweißgebadet dann sind die
nach hause gegangen völlig erschöpft und
nächsten tag standen die wiederum ihre
arbeit getan denn gerade so die pflege
die es in den letzten jahren haben wir
immer gehofft es wird sich mal besser es
wird immer es wurde für uns geklatscht
das erste jahr noch und heute davon ist
gar nichts mehr zu spüren als wir fühlen
uns nach wie vor allein gelassen man
sieht uns nicht man hört uns nicht so es
ist frustrierend
von den acht ungeimpften pflegekräften
haben inzwischen fünf ihre meinung
geändert und auch nikos phat denkt
darüber nach sich vielleicht doch noch
mit dem tod impfstoff impfen zu lassen
noch vor mitte märz soll auch der nach
sachsen geliefert werden